the World Health Organization has
suspended a clinical trial of the anti
malaria drug hydroxychloroquine as a
covered 19 treatment it's cited safety
concerns u.s. president Donald Trump
said recently he was taking the drug but
has since stopped the w-h-o and health
authorities around the world have warned
of the drugs potentially dangerous side
effects there's also no definitive proof
that it is effective against the corona
virus the executive group has
implemented a temporary pause of the
hydroxyl hydroxychloroquine arm within
the Solidarity trial while the data the
safety data is reviewed by the data
safety monitoring board the other arms
of the trial are continuing Lawrence
Boston is a global health law professor
at Georgetown University and he joins us
now from Washington DC thank you for
your time given everything that
president Trump has said about this drug
hydroxychloroquine does this put him in
an awkward situation do you think well
you know unfortunately the president has
never been daunted by clinical evidence
or scientific trials it should give him
pause of course but remember you know
the president Trump's own regulatory
agency in the US Food and Drug
Administration had earlier issued a
warning about using hydroxychloroquine
outside of carefully controlled hospital
conditions or clinical trials and he
ignored his own public health agency he
has a very well-known hostility to the
World Health Organization so I wouldn't
think that this would change his mind at
all but it should what impact has all
this focus on hydroxychloroquine had in
terms of the push to find an actual cure
you know there's been so much attention
on this one drug and also you know for
the people who actually need this drug
hydroxychloroquine well you know it's
it's a huge distraction
it's a political distraction American
scientists understand that that the
evidence is not there for this
particular drug so they're looking at
other medications but you know if the
president keeps touting it and says he's
taking it you run a lot of risks one of
them is is that people will you know
hoard the drug and it won't be available
for people who really need it like those
with rheumatoid arthritis or who are
trying to control malaria the other risk
of course is that patients may take it
you know thinking that somehow they're
protected even though there's zero
evidence that this is a prophylactic or
could prevent covert infections
nonetheless they might you know decide
well I'm taking the drug so I can just
you know go out be with people and
that's very dangerous and so it's just
unacceptable for the President to model
his behavior in such an anti scientific
way do you anticipate that we'll see
more agencies come out and say they're
no longer going to be using this drug in
studies in any way well you know I mean
so far they are and there are studies
ongoing the World Health Organization at
the moment has just paused that arm of
the study while the data safety
monitoring board looks to see whether or
not the evidence suggests that there's
undue risks clinical trials always
should and most do get reviewed by these
kinds of safety boards that which are
independent they're not part of the
study itself and they can pull the trial
if there are red signs warnings that
that that clinical subjects are
to risk and that may well happen if it
does scientists around the world are
gonna have to think well maybe we
shouldn't be even investigating this
drug for this particular purpose thank
for your time as always global health
law professor there Laura Lawrence
gostin thank you